hey guys this is andrew for trading
sensors.com
and i've been working as a trader for
several big investment banks in the past
five years
like hsbc or commerce bank and i've just
started to make some youtube videos
where i want to talk about everything i
see at work the news
the market the different trading
techniques
so if you guys want to know about the
different tools and strategies
that you can use to make money on the
market you are in the right place
now let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so in this first video i
would like to make some technical
analysis with you
on the s p 500 the euro stocks and the
nikkei
so for those who don't know what is
technical analysis it is just about
finding some support levels
and resistance levels in order to kind
of build a framework
where you feel comfortable to trade
where you can more easily
find your stop-loss and your targets to
set that to set up
some nice risk reward trades so
let's start with the s p 500 so this is
the chart i'm having
here so i like to use on my charts the
moving averages
uh the 20 50 and 200 period moving
averages and the macd which is a
momentum
indicator um then i try to make some
trend lines in order
to know where the market could be
possibly heading
so for example i can show you how
i did here so basically to build a trend
line you only need to connect the recent
highs or the recent
lows so for example here i can see that
i have a move down
and i can draw a trend line that is
starting from
the top here going through this
uh middle top and until here
and as you can see once this trendline
has been broken
the market just did a move up and then
we have another move down and another
move up
so basically trendline helps you guys to
find
some stop-loss levels or
resistance levels
so here what i can see is that
the s p 500 to me looks bullish it looks
like we have
one more move up to come on this market
um because
we basically are trading
above this trend line so the level is 35
20 so as long as we stay above 25 20
to me uh we are bullish and i expect the
market to go
somewhere around the 3700 area
within the coming month and i'm gonna
show you why
so to do this i'm gonna use
illiot wave theory so very quickly iliad
wave
uh theory is basically saying that
moves up are developing in five waves
and moves down
are developing in three waves so you
have one two three four five pattern for
moves up
and abc pattern for moves down
um actually it's not moves up and moves
down it's motive waves and corrective
waves of
a motive wave is in the in the direction
of the trend
so here the trend is clearly bullish so
if i have a look
at what happened after uh the kobe 19
crisis and march laws we had a nice
recovery so i'm gonna try to find
five waves here uh in order to kind of
try to guess if this move up is finished
or not
so to do it i use iliad wave
principle so i try to draw five to find
five waves here so one two i would put a
three here
four so four could be here or here it
doesn't really matter and a five
a fifth wave that is coming somewhere
here
so why do i think things are like this
just because as you can see
this you know could have been
like this sorry
if i do my five waves like this all
right this could be possible
but then we should have a kind of deeper
correction than this
you know we should have it should be a
correction in time and spot
so to be corrective enough this move
should be corrective for at least you
know half of the time
this move up last so this lasts around
two
four uh six
six months roughly between march and
september
so i expect at least three months of
move down here i had only um
actually two months of move down and it
didn't go
very low so to me we are still in this
first
move up so that's why i think that we
have a three that is here
a four that is somewhere here
and we don't know where the fifth wave
could go actually we don't have that
many tools to know
how high this market could go we have
fibonacci so fibonacci is just basically
using some
ratios that often happen in the market
using uh the golden number i would do
for those who are interested some videos
uh where i explain in two more details
how is fibonacci working and how you can
use it when you
trade personally i like to use it a lot
it's something that is working well for
me
so here iliot wave uh first um
all right so we are in uh
to me the fifth wave of this whole move
up then we probably gonna have a deeper
correction
all right but before that i think we're
gonna
uh be bullish for at least you know the
third wave
uh last so as we saw around five months
the fourth wave lasts two months so i
expect the fifth wave to last
at least uh two months as well so two
months would bring us
in um in the end
like january 21 something like this so
around here
so i expect this market to go higher
until at least january 21
um and in terms of level i just did a
trendline you know that is connecting
the two recent the two most recent highs
that we had
here and it's basically giving me
as i said some kind of framework where
i know the market would be must
be because you never know for sure but
contained
so i'm pretty sure those markets won't
be trading
uh long above the red
line that we have here so this
bring us at like let's say it's gonna
last until like i don't know february
at 37.50 so this is my target on the s p
500 for the coming
months 37.50 and
this would be invalidated if we break
this blue trendline that is here that is
actually the upper band of my false wave
that is here
so if we trade below roughly 3 500
um i would reconsider my analysis
and maybe i would do things differently
so when what kind of trade
can we make here because this is what we
are interested in what kind of trade can
we make
so for example uh we could buy so you
need
to find so now we are bullish so we need
to find some support level uh
where we have at least two different
signals coming from two different
indicators
uh so it's most it's more likely to
to be to be true so here for example i
have the moving averages
i have the macd so the macd is clearly
positive so the macd
is already giving me a signal that was
here uh
that was actually here so the macd would
say to buy here
why not to me it's like a bit
overextended to buy
here i would have waited you know for
the market to come back on
uh on this trend line but anyway so the
mark
the macd won't give us any good signal
here um
so the signal could come from fibonacci
or
from the the moving averages or the
trend lines
so for example what i would like to see
is something like this
so the moving averages coming here and
the market coming like here
all right and this would be a nice level
to buy
let me show you quickly if i uh
if i go to the four hours time frame
uh and i'm gonna show you how to use
fibonacci so fibonacci
as i said is using some ratios that we
see often
happening in the market so for example
here
if i use fibonacci retracements i just
connect
the recent low and the recent high
of the last move so i want to
see how deep this move can retrace
so i connect this level with this level
all right and this is giving me
the some levels that
you for sure would have some uh
liquidity
some hedge funds buying here or some
retail investors like you and me
that would use fibonacci as well to buy
so this is the reason why
all these indicators kind of work is
because there are a lot of people
using them and the levels you find are
levels
that all the people see too and where
you have a lot of
liquidity a lot of support so for
example here
what i can see is that this level if the
market comes here so on the 24
25th of november so next week if the
market comes to
3 500 it would be actually a very
nice um level to buy
because we would be uh on we would be
retesting
the trend line that we broke um
two weeks ago for the second time it was
retested here once
here almost we tested but if you retest
it again
it would probably act again as support
and we would have the 38.2
um fibonacci retracement which is very
followed by a lot of investors
and we also would have the moving
averages that would be
in this kind of area the 50 period
moving average would be in this area so
this would be for me a nice level to buy
and you could then expect
a nice move up so you you just buy here
um and you stop lost your position maybe
around like
34 50 or something like this so if you
want to have
more um if you want
your trade to be more uh likely
not to be stop lost you can have a stop
loss a bit lower but then
you should invest a little bit less it's
all about risk management
um so here if you buy here
then you could have
you know eight percent move up something
like this all right
eight percent so i buy here and
my target is here so it's a very nice
trade and how much you can lose you can
lose
so if you buy here you stop loss here
okay let's say two percent
two percent so you have a risk uh reward
of four so you can win four times more
than you can lose
so you only need to be right 25 of the
time
all right so technical analysis is not
about being wrong or right
it's not about always being correct
it's about uh risk management and about
about risk rewards all right if you
write only 25 percent of the time on the
on the trade that has a risk reward of
four
then you are profitable so that's it for
me
on the s p 500 let's have a quick
view on the uh euro stocks see how the
euro stocks is behaving
so euro stocks so same this is february
so this
is the highest level the euro stocks
actually traded before the kovid
uh crisis so let's start with the daily
chart so same
i'm using my moving averages i'm using
the macd um
and i tried to make some trend lines all
right
so the first trend line that to me is
the most important one
uh and that occurred actually just
before the kovy 19 vaccine
news where the results of the the phase
3 test of the laboratory
pfizer i think was
positive effective at 90 percent then we
have modena
uh that also had some very good results
on its vaccine test with like
95 percent of effectiveness so which is
very good news for the market and as you
can see during
the market reacted very positively to
this
uh so here um it was
kind of um a very
strong move that was not easy to
trade all right uh not easy to trade
because as i said
so we have a trend trendline that is
here
okay so i connect the height that is
here going through here
and as you can see here i have already a
reaction all right so this trend line
uh is visible um from then
because uh you already have three
nice reactions then here you have the
fourth one so definitely everybody is
seeing this trendline i mean everybody
that is checking this
so you have a lot of support with you
and
here as you can see we just blew
right through it this was i think the
strongest move
that i saw um on the markets in my
career
because it was together with
the snp and the nikkei all the indices
just took i don't know maybe four or
five percent in a matter of
uh hours so let's have a quick view
if we could have um how we could have
traded this so i go to the 30 minutes
time frame
because this is how if you do if you do
the day trading this is how you trade
all right
you are in a 30 minutes or one hour time
frame
and you basically spot some
resistance and once you go through it
you know it's kind of the time to buy
but you never buy the breakout guys
never buy the breakout
it is uh too
risky because you don't really know
where to put your stop loss you wait for
the
the trend line to be broken and once it
come back
when once it comes back to it then it's
the time to buy
so for example here it was not easy to
get this one all right
definitely um
[Music]
you you didn't have much opportunity to
buy here because it was it was not
retested
all right and this move was just insane
this is a 6.5 move
in in that happened
in uh all right three hours
three hours six point five percent it's
like you know
it's just insane insane um
so then what happened next
uh we just
blew right through this chain line as i
said so
uh from from here we're bullish and
and then we had another uh resistance
that was to me
quite clear and that you see
well in the hourly chart
so this is the green line that i have
here so i just connect you know
the the maximum the highest point that i
had
before the breakout so this is this
point all right
and as you can see so here it was a bit
messy
but here i have um
so here this trend line acted as
resistance and here it acted as
resistance as well
so this level is to me something that is
quite
uh watched by the other investors
and as you can see we broke it and we
came back we tested it
this is and this was for example a nice
trade to set up you can buy here stop
plus your position here
and then you have this move up to come
so what can we do
now so as i said i'm bullish on the snp
so of course those indices are all
correlated
and we have good news coming from the
market we have biden that has
uh warmed us presidential elections
um it's not all uh it's a bit denied
still
by uh donald trump but markets don't
take him very seriously you know
he's using some tricks um that are a bit
ridiculous
he's saying for example that the
democrats voters
a lot of them are actually dead people
and
he also like his supporters gave a list
of those
uh alleged dead people and actually a
lot of people say
sorry i'm still alive it's me and
and just the least was completely wrong
as a lot of
things that he was saying after he
lost the election so basically markets
are not taking
the threat very seriously for now
the only issue could be for me uh kind
of small
social tensions between trump and
biden's
supporters but for now it is contained
and biden is just waiting for trump
to be tired of denying the
the truth it's that he has lost the
election
so the markets are happy that biden won
because he has a very strong stimulus
package that would come
it's about 2.2 trillion uh dollars which
is
2 000 more than 2 000 billion dollars
guys
it's very big money so and this insane
flow of money
is actually what is driving the markets
higher
all right so the vaccine news helps but
the
the reason for me for those markets to
go up despite some
bad economic outlook to be coming in the
coming month
years is that there is an unlimited flow
of money in the markets
and this money needs to go somewhere
so it won't go in the rates because the
rates are very low as you know
to sustain the economy we have some very
accommodative
economic policies with some very low
rates so you won't
buy those rates because you won't
receive much for your money
so you buy the equity that's what all
the big
institutional clients hedge funds are
doing because they have no choice they
need to find some
return somewhere and so they find it on
the equity market
so this is the reason why it will go
higher for me
and how far it can go
this answer can be given by technical
analysis
so once again i come back to the euro
stocks so here
um this is now our uh strongest support
all right
at 3400 roughly so what can we do
same as on the s p we won't buy here
we will wait for the market to come
re-test
again this resistance and once again we
are trying to use
um some levels where we have
signals coming from different indicators
so
once again what kind of indicators we
have trend line
moving averages macd fibonacci so if i
do some fibonacci
um rezoning here
i'm just connecting the lowest point
here with the highest point here
and i would say that the nice level to
buy is
as always the 38.2 percent or the 50
feet retracements those levels are very
watched by other investors
and you will find liquidity here that
would push the market higher
you have the moving averages that is
already higher so as you can see the
moving average is already
above the 50 percent so
if the market comes back here you could
buy
already but i wouldn't take this trade
because this move has not retraced yet
and i'm a bit afraid that after such a
strong move up we could have
we could have some uh deeper correction
than
only
1.5 percent uh i think that this market
needs to you know uh
get some fresh energy some fresh
liquidity and to find this liquidity it
needs to go a bit
lower so i would say maybe a five
percent move down
in the coming weeks would be a very nice
opportunity for us to buy so once again
i'm bullish
in the coming month but i'm kind of
mutual almost
bearish in the coming days weeks i think
this market has
been extended a lot uh since the us
presidential elections
so uh early november and that it needs
to correct
to push higher it needs to correct first
to push
higher so we can see that
here let me go to the four hour time
frame
in the four hours time frame you can see
that the macd is already
negative all right the magnitude is i
mean the magnet is positive
but we had the crossover of the macd and
the exponential moving average of the
max itself which is the signal given by
the macd
so here we have a bearish signal so
maybe we can wait for this to
become green again we can wait for the
macd signal to turn positive
and we can wait to come at those levels
so
i would for example the kind of trade i
would do
is to buy here so buy at 32
uh 70 buy again at 3200 all right you
buy once you buy a second time because
i'm very convinced that this market
would go higher so i'm uh i'm okay to
buy at different levels and you stop
lost your position here
all right so for example you buy here
you buy here so in average you buy at 30
to
35 and you stop loss at
3170 so it's like 60 points so you can
so you would lose
60 points and how much you can make guys
where is the next resistance
here it's almost a no man's land all
right we have
no more resistance coming before the big
one that is here
so i think this market so if you buy
here all right you can have a 17
percent move up guys all right in the
coming month
so i think that this is a very risk very
nice risk we would trade
that you can do um
last but not least nikkei very quickly
so we have the kind of the same
environment
so we broke some major so let me go back
to the daily
we broke some major resistance uh
during the u.s presidential elections
and
after the vaccine news so the resistance
level was 40 24 000
and we are just going higher every day
since
then so where this market could be
heading same
kind of reasoning i'm trying to find uh
a level where i have different
indicators giving me a signal
so uh i'm using trendline once again
so i connect the two most recent highs
here and here all right
and so this trend line is giving me
some resistance and if i go to the
weekly
i want to try where i want to try to see
where is the highest point
before that all right so as i said here
is like a bit
as on the euro stocks even more it's a
complete no man's land
it has been uh an area where
the nikkei was not going since
1991 guys and the highest level in 1991
in march
was actually 27 000. so i'm pretty sure
that the nikkei is going there did go
there
before correcting i don't know i don't
know but i won't buy here because if you
buy here
you need to stop last here and your
target is here so basically your risk
reward
is quite bad because you can lose six
percent
in order to make five percent all right
so this is not a good trader
this is not the kind of trend that i
like to take
so i would wait for the market to come
back here and i would do as i do on the
s
p and on the euro stocks i would buy
here and i would try to take this move
up
about 13 and how much would i be
ready to lose for that um
[Music]
i would put my stop loss maybe here you
know
so i would lose maybe two percent so
it's a very
nice okay three percent i would put my
stop loss here
so once again where would i put my stop
loss i can use this trend line to
make a stop loss just below it i can
also
use a trendline so let me go back to the
daily
and i can say that for example if the
market is going
sorry this is not what i want to do
all right bam bam so this is my trend
line so for example
here you can see if the market is going
below this one
and this one and for example we also
have the macd turning negative
this is really the time to cut to stop
your position all right
so this level 24 000 would be a nice
level to buy and use stop-loss just
below it
okay guys that's it for me i hope i'm an
age to make to make myself
clear and to show you some cool things
that i like to do
so once again i repeat i like to use
illiot wave
principle fibonacci retracements trend
lines
macd and moving averages this is how i
build my framework and where i'm
comfortable to take some trades alright
guys that's it for me i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did
please hit the like button and the
subscribe button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
it also tells me that you like what i do
and that i should keep doing this
and for those who trade today be careful
guys we still expect a lot of volatility
up ahead
stay close to shore